pour le lead à elisa ses préparations de
commandes dans leur entreprise cassis et
malice elles ont dû mettre de côté leur
activité de traiteur et ont décidé de
livrer des repas à domicile pour les
particuliers et le personnel soignant
on avait envie de faire quelque chose
pour les soignants qui se mobilisent en
ce moment et du coup on a lancé une
canette sur le site internet qui
permettait à la base de vendre les repas
pour proposer aux personnes qu'ils
souhaitent d'offrir un repas à hauteur
de 8 euros pour des soignants donc en
gros au off la matière première une
matière première de qualité nous on
cuisine et ensuite on va livrer
différents établissements aujourd'hui on
va livrer deux ehpad pour les livraisons
les deux gérantes ont dû s'adapter et
appliquer des gestes barrières sur le
chemin elles se rendent dans des
commerces de proximité pour récupérer
quelques dons avant de se diriger vers
les pattes de la mgen
nous on est effectivement à l'arrêt mais
il y en a qui se bat tous les jours pour
essayer de ba de soigner au mieux les
personnes touchées par locaux vides ou
les personnes qui sont un peu plus
faibles et du coup on a essayé bas de
rejoindre des circuits qui était déjà
mis en place
on a de par la distance c'est un peu
compliqué donc on a mis ça en place
au menu ce midi pour l'équipe soignante
linguini truite brocoli et asperges du
fait maison qui ravissent est cadre de
santé
ce qui me touche c'est de voir qu'il ya
beaucoup d'élan de solidarité de la part
de beaucoup de d'entreprise qui
finalement peuvent être en difficulté
financière mais qui malgré tout
continuent à faire des dons 2 et des
dons via des offres de repas un élan de
solidarité que le personnel soignant
espère voir se prolonger
notamment pour le matériel médical comme
les masques élégant qui pourraient venir
à manquer